week a radical new plan or the same old
tune that was defeated back in 2014.
i'll talk to the man who led his country
closer to independence than anyone else
alex salmond a lot has happened to mr
salmond since then what does he make of
his former proteges new push
and what is it like to be held in an
egyptian jail activist sana saif was
sentenced to 18 months for spreading
false news her brother's still being
detained in and out of prison in egypt
for his role in the arab spring uprising
of 2011.
sana and her family are fighting for his
release but should the british
government be helping too the family are
after all british citizens we hear their
story
the brexit agreement was put into
turmoil this week when the government
here decided to override the northern
ireland protocol the eu commissions
called it unrealistic i went to brussels
to speak to vice president maris
sekovich and get his reaction
vice president thanks for talking to us
today um let's start with the trying
week it's the difficult week but before
we do
can we reflect a bit or you reflect on
your the relationship between london and
brussels how bad do you think the
current uk eu
relations are now compared with
recent history
from one side i have to say that our
cooperation on ukraine and global
challenges is remarkable this is how we
would like
to see it because i always repeat that
for us
the uk
is a strategic partner it's ally it's
eternal neighbor and it's a very
important commercial
partner as well so we would like really
to kind of move our relationship on the
greener posture to really have that very
well functioning
bilateral relationship and of course
therefore i have to say
that if you are
going to discuss still the pertinent
brexit issue the pity that we have to
spend
so much time on them especially when we
need to build and consolidate this
western unity is the brexit difficulties
bleeding into other areas of cooperation
is it cast in a shadow it is because of
course uh the eu uk relationship is is
very it's very massive i mean so we
cooperate on a lot of fields and if you
have
um the situation where after a very
arduous and difficult negotiations and
agreement on the agreements like
withdrawal agreement
northern northern ireland protocol and
then of course
the trade and cooperation agreements and
we thought that we've done that
we agreed upon it we ratified it and we
are still talking about it and
of course what is extremely sensitive
for us and what what is indeed very
damaging for our relationship is this uh
constant breaching of the of the
international law and that's something
what we've been not used to
uh from the uk
on the breaching and and that making it
difficult from a european union
perspective over the past few days
members of the european parliament and
the darling island have said they can't
trust prime minister boris johnson or
foreign secretary liz truss their words
not to be taken is that your view as
well on that foundation we built the
trade and cooperation agreement it's
very much based on trust because i think
for the first time in the history of the
european union we actually accepted
that the external controls and checks on
our external border will be actually
performed by uk authorities this uh you
know breaching of the international law
makes it very difficult and uh and it's
very damaging to our mutual trust does
it make it difficult for you to trust
these people when you're trying to
negotiate i always do the positive
attitude
to my interlocutors and and i have
always respect for them because
they are representing their country they
are representing the the political
political interest and i always hope for
the better i mean that's i think what
the diplomats need to do but of course
i have to say that since march of the of
the last year we have a permanent
threat of unilateral measures article
16
announcements and now we have
the draft bill which is clearly illegal
and which is of course making
our life here very difficult and
therefore i hope that with the proposals
which we put
on the table yesterday we flesh them out
in very concrete form that we can bring
our uk partners back to the negotiating
table because i think we need to find
the good solution well let's let's get
on to some of the proposals that the uk
and the european union have
suggested
you just said it again you you are
convinced that the uk has acted
illegally in laying this legislation in
you the uk parliament that will override
parts of the uh the northern ireland
protocol agreed in the withdrawal treaty
by the european union and the uk back in
2020
to quote your comments yesterday you
said there's no legal or political
justification whatsoever for changing
unilaterally an international agreement
the uk
government you know has a very different
perspective to you they say that this
has legal justification they use the
doctrine of necessity in international
law which allows a state to act in the
event of a grave risk to their interests
which is what the uk government has
concluded so i put it to you that that
might be your perspective but that's
certainly not the perspective of the
government in london i honestly think
that you
don't have to be a lawyer to see that
this
draft is clearly illegal and i just
would give you one very clear example i
mean there is
no way
that the uk would decide what kind of
goods
may enter into the european single
market
our uk counterparts they knew perfectly
well what they are signing up to and i
have to say that if it comes to the
northern ireland specific solution the
northern ireland
uh protocol it was expressed which of
this uk government so they they be
negotiating with us
line by line we've been jointly looking
for the solutions how to protect peace
in northern ireland how to avoid
the hard border how to make sure the
good friday belfast agreement is
respected in all its dimension and the
protocol was the result so that's that's
the only solution after arduous
negotiation and looking at it from from
from all the sides which is now being
undermined so what what we are offering
here is permanent solution
usa is
following this very very closely i mean
when i was
in washington dc a couple of months ago
i have to say that this was the question
which was featured quite prominently in
all the meetings i had
in white house the state department and
especially in the congress and it was
just a couple of weeks ago we had very
important
congressional delegation here and first
and foremost what is the most important
for united states as it is for us to
maintain the peace
respect the good friday of belfast
agreement and to sort it out the usa
have made it clean clear to you that
they also do not support the uk's
unilateral action what i heard from our
u.s partners always was work together
work for the joint solutions and
especially
in in congress but also in the state
department and
in
in the white house
they they know that the protocol is the
answer but they want us to work out on
how to smooth more the operation how to
address this unintended consequence and
this is exactly what we are proposing to
do but to deliver that we need
engagement and political will from
london and vice president i want to get
into a bit of the sort of sticking
points between the uk uh and brussels at
the moment but but from a uk perspective
and you will know this the protocol
isn't working in that the uk
government's job is to uphold the good
friday group you just said it was the
most important thing for all parties but
power sharing in northern ireland is not
happening
and that's as a direct consequence of
the protocol
i mean
the government has to do something if
they can't get power sharing working in
northern ireland you you accept that
don't you
of course we do not want to interfere in
the internal politics of uk and northern
ireland and i think
it's for the people of northern ireland
to decide on all these very important
issues where we see our task is just to
recall that
the first two articles in the protocol
on ireland northern ireland are
about full respect of the good friday
belfast agreement in knowledge dimension
and second one is on
full respect of territorial integrity
and constitutional arrangements of the
uk and we fully respect that
what
uh where we differ is the fact that we
see
that the protocol is actually the the
the solution uh for maintaining the
peace for protecting the good friday
belfast agreement and for avoiding the
hard border and and bringing this uh
additional prosperity to the northern
ireland
economy and
therefore we are in i would say
permanent contact with the key
stakeholders in northern ireland just to
present them our view of uh all these
developments but the key here are the
unionists as you know the democratic
union's party will not enter the parish
sharing arrangement with the protocol as
it stands and they want wholesale
changes hence the government's
legislation they need to get this work
and they need to get the northern
ireland assembly have you spoken to the
dep about your proposals this week i
have to say that we are in in i would
say permanent contact with the key
stakeholders in
northern ireland beat northern irish
business leaders civic society but also
political leaders and
i invited
all political leaders
to talk to us and i'm ready to talk to
them at any time
i have met uh in the past several times
with sergio free
and i was underlining one very important
uh things that we want uh to deliver or
on all uh unintended consequences of the
protocol and we want to do it in a
constructive way what we do not need is
a political victory in in this
these debates
i uh we are not here for political
scoring that the eu is right and you
prevailed in these negotiations we
really want to solve the problem
vice president you you said though just
to pick up on that that the eu are not
into political point scoring do you
think that the uk government is partly
doing this for political point scoring
i cannot
resist the impression that
the tabling of the build is politically
driven
uh but it's not our role to comment uh
on uh internal politics in the in the uk
and therefore
uh our doors for the negotiations will
always be open i'm ready to talk to all
political leaders in northern ireland to
all stakeholders and and to work on uh
what is the only solution in this
difficult situation and this is joint
approach these are the permanent
solutions vice president you just said
that you think it could be
something to do with domestic politics
in the uk are you suggesting what what
do you mean by that what are you
suggesting
i think that uh what uh currently uh we
would uh very much uh uh appreciate this
uh the uh
more of a political will to work uh on
these issues
you don't think the prime minister of
the uk does you think that there's
another agenda he's following here
i wouldn't i wouldn't comment on
domestic politics in the uk but what i
can tell you is that
um already in february
we proposed to our
uk partners a quite
detailed roadmap what do you think we
should discuss on technical expert level
in the period of pre-election campaign
uh in in northern ireland and until
today we didn't get the response so what
i want to say if this issue is so urgent
why uh we didn't use the time more
efficiently why we didn't work on these
joint solutions and yesterday you
announced you'd resume previously paul's
legal action uh against uk for failing
to implement the border checks for goods
arriving from ni to gb
i put it to you that that doesn't really
resolve anything it just it it just
escalates the situation further
what i have to say is that
as you know we we put our legal action
in freezer last year
and it was also the gesture of a
goodwill from from our side because we
wanted to create conducive space for
there for the negotiations but as i told
you there was a radio silence from
london since february
we got this unilateral
uh draft bill which is really damaging
the trust in our relationship and we
just simply have to defend
our interests so we have to start
the legal action but again what is very
important to underscore
we would act
proportionate we would be gradual in our
responses because we want to keep doors
open and we still hope
that
we will uh get our uk partners back to
the negotiating table can you rule out a
trade war i think you're saying you
can't what i want to say is that we've
been building uh our new post-brexit
relationship on very clear fundament and
first one was miserable agreement part
of it is the protocol
island in northern ireland and on on
this
two fundamental pieces we built the
trade and cooperation agreement but if
you pull the rack
from under the feet of this of this of
this of this construction then of course
we have a fundamental issue
uh with uh
you know the whole architecture and
therefore we cannot exclude anything so
you can't exclude a trade war
if you're boris johnson in london uh
listening to this you're thinking yeah
yeah trade war could come in 33 years
time is your the eu process right so
three years time is after the next
election i mean in a way politically
it's it's meaningless in that it's a
it's a it's an empty threat isn't it
at this point in in negotiations
we are not in the business of threats as
a
eu and uh from the i mean moment one
when we've been negotiating this level
agreement protocol dca we've been the
only party i have to say which was
bringing constructive ideas to the table
and we did it in the course of the last
year despite the lots of union
unilateral elections taken
uh by the uk and we are doing it now it
was a i would say big part of our
presentation yesterday was what we
uh offer uh to solve this problem how
this can be done and the propositions we
put on the table will tick i would say
uh
all the all the all the boxes on what we
hear uh from the northern ireland if it
comes to sps controls if it comes to the
customs procedures and on top of it
we'll will
bring back
permanent solution will bring back
uh the access to the biggest trading
block in the in the world and
i think would really calm down the the
atmospherics between the eu and the uk
let me put it another way then you
you can't take the threat of a trade war
off the table i know you don't like the
word threat
but you but you don't really think it's
it it's likely you think that there can
be a solution before each side neither
side wants that as the outcome do they
you think you can work this out of
course it would be our uh it would be
our preference i mean therefore we we
went into this very special i would say
uh institutional and agreement set up
with the uk which really important as i
as i would remind and recall once again
we ask the uk to perform the checks on
the goods which are entering european
single market how much more we can
demonstrate our our trust and we need uh
you know that this would be that this
would be done according to the according
to the to the rules and of course we
would prefer to have uh fructose normal
relationship with the with the uk but at
the same time
we also have to defend our interests
vice president i just want to bring you
quickly on something else regarding that
on the checks there would be some in the
uk government that think
they're not enforcing checks now and
they just don't enforce any checks so
you're in a situation where the uk
government won't enforce any checks
checks on goods uh going
north south on the island of ireland so
going from the from the european from
the uk into the european union what are
you going to do
if the uk government did that would you
at any point
put any
checks on the border north south at hard
border on that side is that a
possibility do you absolutely rule that
out
i'm absolutely ruling out the hard
border
and
of course this would be additional i
would say illegality in our
relationship and though we'll just
discuss with the with the member states
and with the european parliament what
should be the course of further action
because indeed
we
have to make sure that public health
not only of
the people in the european union but
also in the people in the northern
island is not under the threat and here
maybe one additional point which i would
like to make until now
um
i have to say that the convergence
uh between the rules in the in the in in
the uk
and the eu
been
rather big but if of course uk would
proceed
with this
divergence agenda and the standards uh
would simply be more wider apart then
it could be of course a more and more
problematic uh question and therefore
i think it's it's quite important to
stick to what we agreed upon that if it
comes to northern ireland it would it
would have access to the single market
and the taxes is based on respecting the
euros
just quickly though you you've you've
clearly ruled out a hard border on the
island of ireland north south what about
the idea of checkpoints
or border posts or so but you rule out
all of that no checks no cameras nothing
on the border
i mean we we ask for the border points
between gb and northern ireland and that
was the
scene that's that was clearly the the
part of the agreement and
and that's
actually
one
issue
which we are complaining about in our
legal
legal legal action
and
this is how we agree that we would solve
and therefore we want to stick to the
international law to the agreement we
have signed
just to round up um
how confident are you that this can be
resolved you did publish some
suggestions uh on customs this week it
does seem that the uk intransigence has
helped move the european union a bit do
you do you think that we can
resolve this
and that the european union and the uk
can properly move on and put brexit to
bed
i think
here we have to follow the the very
common rule
hope for the best be prepared for the
worst
this is what
we will be we will be doing here
and
we will be
permanently pointing
to the huge advantages of our approach
over unilateral
proposals which came from the uk because
we really have
the
the interests of people of northern
ireland in heart
we
absolutely want to make sure that they
would benefit
from the access to the single market
from having the possibility to export to
500 million people and we want
to provide them with legal certainty
with clarity with stability and
for these goals we are
ready to work with uk government and
with all
political leaders in northern ireland
okay vice president thank you very much
i hope the talks do resume soon and and
uh we'd love to talk to you again in a
few months see how things are going
thank you thank you very much for
inviting me
and if you scan this qr code on screen
right now you can watch all of our
interviews online and all of the
previous episodes of the show if you so
desire
well stay with us because coming up next
egyptian activist and filmmaker sannet
cf who is campaigning to get her brother
freed from a jail in egypt
[Music]
welcome back allad ab al-fatah has been
in and out of an egyptian jail since
2011
an activist he had a prominent role in
the arab spring uprising after an appeal
from the united nations he was released
but he's currently serving time in
prison for a facebook post criticizing
the government his family are trying to
get help from the uk government to get
him freed earlier i spoke to his sister
sana currently living in the uk and once
arrested and imprisoned herself about
their campaign
sanji thanks for coming on the show
today um we want to talk about your
story today but i want to talk to you
first about your brother allah who's
detained in egypt
before we get on to what's happening
with him can you tell me a bit about him
thank you for having me hers
ale
publicly is known to be a
programmer
writer uh and
a pro-democracy secular human rights
activist yeah but as a person like as a
brother he's um he's my older brother
i'm the
the baby sister
so
we're friends but there's also this
mentorship kind of uh
dynamic
he's um
he's the person in the family who's he's
he's a bit of an
he's always been kind of a nerd he likes
to read a lot he's
about everything to know engage with
everything can you tell me sort of what
happened to him and how he ended up in
prison how he got out of prison and why
he's back in prison now we were
interested in the political situation
in egypt
my father my belief father was a human
rights lawyer and ale because he was a
programmer and technologist he was
really interested in
empowering people
like
localizing tools making them available
in arabic and by by by that empowering
people to
to communicate and to organize that was
pre
pre the like the social media movement
and so when 2011 happened he kind of
became a prominent figure because of the
work he did in the bloggers movement
and
with the family background
we gained some prominence and then in
2013 when the when the backlash happened
and the military
uh
basically
took charge
we became one of the
as a family but especially we became one
of the main targets of the regime so he
he went to prison in in
2011 he was he was released and he's now
back
in prison why does president sisi see
him as such a threat because he
means something to other people that
he's a symbol of what rebellion of an
alternative future
he seems to be a real threat to the
government or they perceive him to be
yeah it's something that this we don't
know for sure why
i mean
our assessment is that they kind of
we had the little we were known by a few
people before the attack like the
vicious attack happened to us in 2013
but i think they kind of created their
own uh
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
they
because they tried to set an example
with ale and so they've so viciously
attacked him and
was
sentenced to five years for a
demonstration and a demonstration he he
did not
organize where the organizers actually
went to court and showed evidence that
they are the organizers
and the court decided to uh to to to
dismiss
that so he served five years for that
and he started fighting and then he came
and he came out and then he re-arrested
him again and put him on your choices
for for a facebook post uh a
facebook post he did not write a
physical post he shared about human
rights
have violations happening in a prison so
the details are could could be confusing
and
are not confusing but exhausting
to tell and to listen to but
but i think it's that so you sorry
so you he was falsely so the so there
was what it was a false imprisonment
well the first time you would argue it
was a false imprisonment for the second
time they kind of constructed a case to
to re-arrest him yeah both time
constructed
and
actually in egypt it's quite a known
fact now that the legal uh
things are just details that
everybody knows the alle is not so
technically allah is in prison for a
facebook post
but everybody knows that genuinely and
is not imprisoned for a facebook post so
he's in prison because he represents
something he represents
um
something for
for a younger generation how's he doing
in prison have you seen him
last time i saw allah was in march
before i left cairo my sister saw him
last week
so the way we see ale is
for the past three years the visits are
behind the glass shield with a
in april 2nd he
he started a hunger strike
so today would be the
75 of his hunger strike i haven't seen
him since the hunger strike but what my
sister explains to me is really
terrifying
because i was outside the country
last visit my sister came out type what
i called i called her and my mom
they really sounded distressed they said
um
he looks very weak
it's like his only skin on bones
mona my sister
because of
because of how shocked she was she
couldn't eat since
and
she just told me i feel like i have to
use my body as a portal
to show that what's happening to ale
because
the egyptian authorities are are
are are using
the fact that they can hide him in a in
a dark cell and not show to them
today would be her fourth day
um
that's difficult okay well sorry you
should explain from the beginning right
it's fine though it's fine
um
okay so what led to the strike
was that
he for the past few years his conditions
were really really bad he wasn't allowed
anything he was
isolated from any outside input so he
wasn't allowed books time outside of his
cell
he would they wouldn't even allow him a
clock to be aware of the time of the day
right
and
he was in a maximum security prison that
is built on the whole premise of the war
on terrorism while he's not on terrorism
charges he's actually on a misdemeanor
and it's a freedom of expression issue
but it's also like legally in his
demeanor
um
so
we kept on uh filing complaints but but
it led to nothing so allah decided
he was feeling really that because in
prison you don't have agency over
anything but your body yeah so when he
was totally fed up when he couldn't take
it anymore he decided to start a hunger
strike yeah
yeah so for on day 55 when when they
made this little compromise from their
behalf he also made a little compromise
and started taking 100 calories a day he
said i switched to a a gandhi style
strike right okay so a human being
should take around 2 000 calories a day
alex takes 100 calories
um if his conditions improve or if he
gets consumer access he could make more
compromises just before we get to
his release and your campaign i just
wanted to ask you
about your time in prison because
you know far you were also arrested
weren't you can you tell us what
happened to you
yeah so
um i was imprisoned
over the past 10 years three times each
of those times has a story but they all
come down to one thing to
the fact that as family we're being
punished because we're vocal about
the assaults or the
violations that happen to ali so this
last time i served a year and a half
sentence i was arrested after trying to
to get a letter into my brother let's
get back to your brother
he spent a lot of time in detention
he's got a sentence until 2027
i believe um how
hopeful
are you of of getting him out and have
you received any assistance
from the uk government to help you your
mother was born
in the uk and you are all jew citizens
and so he does fall under the remit
of the uk government
yeah i'm for the first time now in the
last nine years i'm actually very
hopeful although we are at a moment of
desperation but we also at the moment of
possibility
allah's case is very complicated if you
think of it locally but
there is precedence
uh
and there is a law that was issued in
2015
for dual nationals for specifically
cases like ale alejandra's president
with the u.s
with australia and with france
that
they would basically for political
prisoners
they would basically renounce their
other citizenship and be deported to
their other country of residence and and
uh
and of course
in our last case if he would if he was
deported here
none of the the case file here wouldn't
be i mean he wouldn't be considered a
criminal
and this is obviously a freedom of
expression issue you need the foreign
secretary to get involved yes we need to
we need the foreign secretary and i'm
and i'm confused i'm not sure why
because i i can see that there is a lot
of sympathy i can see that
there is support we're always in touch
with the embassy
um and so i'm confused as to why we
haven't met with the foreign secretary
yet so you haven't met with the foreign
secretary if you could ask the prime
minister or the foreign secretary liz
truss to do one thing what would it be
to
well
to to meet with us
basically but ultimately i know that
a firm phone call
from the prime minister
followed by
a robust negotiation from the fcdo we
get out
i know that we've seen that with the
french we've seen that
with the americans you've recently
joined forces with richard ratcliffe and
you've also just had more than a
thousand celebrities from dame judi
dench to mark ruffalo carrie mulligan
urgent uh liz trusted foreign secretary
um and the u.s used council anthony
blinken to use their diplomatic force to
try and
get your brother freed
um you've got momentum now
but you still think the british
government aren't really listening is it
just not a priority for them because
they've got other more important in
their
views
i'm really confused that's why i'm
really confused i see sympathy and we
have momentum and we have solidarity and
support from other governments in the
west
and
relationships between egypt and britain
are very strong this is not something
that's going to jeopardize those
relationships actually this gives
the uk leverage um
that's why i am i'm genuinely puzzled as
to why we're not getting the attention
we need from the foreign secretary how
hopeful are you that you might be able
to see your brother not behind
a glass
partitioned but actually face to face by
the end of this year's say
again i'm i'm now hopeful more than ever
ale is not unfortunately
but i understand that from his
perspective
alle believes he's gonna die in prison
um
i'm hopeful i'm really hopeful and i and
i think it's easy it's simple if we get
to the right people
and i think
there is precedence
um
we know the recipe
as to how to do it french did it the us
did it and uk is definitely capable of
doing it
okay
well sana thank you so much for telling
us your story and um and i hate your
brother i hope your brother gets out
soon and
gets healthy and gets to see you and his
son and and all his family again thank
you thank you thank you for having me
it's pleasure
well we got a response from the uk
foreign office about this case
the uk government continues to raise
allah abdel fatter's case at the highest
levels of the egyptian government we are
working urgently to secure consular
access to mr abdel fattah we are also
concerned by reports that he's on a
sustained hunger strike the welfare of
british nationals in detention remains a
high priority
well stay with us because coming up next
former fast minister of scotland alex
salmond
[Music]
the former fast minister of scotland
alex salmond once led the country in an
independence referendum
under the leadership of nicolas sturgeon
his protege there's a new bid for
scotland to break away from the uk but
she faces pressure from her former boss
who is demanding more action on the
plans earlier i spoke to mr salmond
about his role in scottish politics
since leaving office and the controversy
around him
mr simon thanks for joining us on the
show today i'm actually as you know i'm
in brussels uh you're in london i'm here
because i was talking to maris sekovich
today about some of the consequences of
the uk leaving the european union a
union it's been in for nearly 50 years
this week your successor first minister
nicholas sturgeon launched plans for
that second independence referendum what
did you think of her proposals
well i mean apart from the comparison
with other countries which is a
perfectly fair thing to do because it's
right and proper to make the point that
other small european countries are doing
much better than the uk is doing it
economically there wasn't really much
proposals beyond that but of course were
promised
a series of papers to come i suppose
like many people in the national
movement i'm just i'm just
pleased that the starting gun has
eventually been fired because they've
been waiting on it for some considerable
time
and do you think she's the right person
to lead this campaign and would you
share a platform with her
well yes the second part your question
in terms of being the right person she's
the inevitable person to lead the
campaign she's the head of the scottish
government the scottish government have
a a prime role in the independence
referendum i i don't think we should
have the the only role incidentally i
think it's really really important that
our voices from outwith government
who are proclaiming independence i asked
you partly because obviously there's
kind of quite a lot of personal
animosity between the two of you
at the moment or is that now being
cleared up well i've been part of a
personal difference between myself and
nicholas i mean that they are
insignificant compared to the the
national cause of scotland becoming
independent which i and nicola sturgeon
have devoted to our lives so i don't
think you would find
any personal difficulties
coming in the way of what something
which is much bigger much greater than
any two individuals
i just want to ask you about what you
think brexit has done to this
possible solution for scotland nicholas
sturgeon has made it clear she still
wants to join the european union and the
single market that's what you once
wanted i think
uh but brexit's changed your mind is
that right
well i've changed mind in the sense that
i think it'd be a better option for
scotland at least initially but perhaps
in the long term to be in the european
free trade association and the
four-member
association
there are many advantages of that but i
think the prime advantage is well it
takes perhaps five years
to join the european union uh whereas
after what takes about three months to
join having the security of after
membership strikes me as a very good
idea indeed then you can decide over the
longer term if whether the people of
scotland want to go in for the uh
to the european union brexit you would
acknowledge has complicated the picture
a bit for scotland would you would you
agree with that i mean nicolas sturgeon
got into quite a lot of hot water or
difficulties uh in that press conference
when people repeatedly asking her about
what we're seeing now in northern
ireland and the read across for scotland
and is there going to be a hard border
between scotland and england that that's
a massive problem isn't it i mean scots
might want to be independent they might
not want a hard border if you've you've
said complication difficulties and hard
border in the same question uh i mean i
think part of the difficulties thinking
under the press conference was they
haven't published their proposals on
europe yet
if we're taking the non-irish example
well what the border non-island has
meant with their
total access to the single market has
been a prosperity for northern ireland
in relative terms at least for the first
time in recorded economic statistics in
northern ireland as a top of the table
in terms of the nations and regions of
the united kingdom
in this interview we're not we're not
solving the problems of northern ireland
but we're looking at the northern irish
example to see what it tells us about
scotland and what it tells us and you
wouldn't nobody would describe nobody
serious personally you know perhaps the
union expressed in scotland might
describe the minister of borders and the
idc is a hard border do you accept
though that um there would be checks on
goods between england and scotland or
you think there's a way to avoid that
because
well the center would be checks at the
border i mean the the the maximum you'd
have certainly on an extra proposal
it's moving between the two countries a
point of saw some point of origin now
yes that's one of the that's one of the
consequences now there are advantages of
that the primary advantage would be that
you'd have full access to a single
market 500 million people so you know
there are pros and cons swings and
roundabouts all i'm pointing out to you
isn't not around in economic terms it
will lead to one side the politics yes
the pros have been much greater than the
cons how likely do you think there will
be a referendum before the next general
election then
well i mean i i take the scottish
government as word i mean it's a no ifs
no buts uh commitment now that there's
going to be a referendum by october of
next year so the national movement
scotland are looking forward to taking
part in that referendum you could see a
scenario where the where hollywood
legislate for a referendum but they
don't hold a referendum could you see
that as a possibility i see many
scenarios but the first thing to do is
to ask for it to let boris johnson deny
it to let him deny the will of the
scottish parliament and then take
effect of political election to change
his mind
as i say my view is that boris johnson
is not a strong political figure i think
you know
it's an open question as if he'll even
be prime minister by the autumn
and therefore this seems to me a very
good time to exert
political and democratic pressure you
were taken to court in 2020 on a series
of sexual assault charges you were
acquitted of all of those charges
um and at the time some of your allies
suggested you'd been a victim of a witch
hunt within the scottish national party
you then went on
with allegations that there was a
conspiracy against you designed to cause
your downfall and even imprisonment that
was unproven we had the hollywood
inquiry in the investigation by james
hamilton
both strongly criticized nicolas
sturgeon but they didn't say there was
an organized conspiracy
it was a torrid time have you come to
terms with all of that put it behind you
is that saga now over
well certainly it's not going to get in
the way of an independence campaign
i mean there's a police investigation
ongoing into illegal leaks of material
from the scottish government there's
also a crown investigation or a clown
review of possible perjury
at the high court trial and now these
things must be allowed to take the
course they're in the hands of the
police and
the crown office and obviously i've
given
evidence to both of these because i
would like to see them come to
conclusion has it politically damaged
you know the reason i ask is that
nicholas sturgeon uh said uh from her
own conversations with you and i'm going
to quote her she said his behavior was
inappropriate and she said she'd search
your testimony for signs of reflection
and recognition of your behavior but
there was not a single word to
acknowledge that do you acknowledge that
your behavior towards women
at times was was inappropriate
i'm not going to go over what was well
gone over well-trod material beth that's
in the hands of a police investigation
in the hands of the crown officer
nothing i'm going to say is going to
enter i appear in these ongoing no um
this is really important before there's
a police investigation into criminal
leaks from within the scottish
government there's a crown off
investigation to possible perjury at the
trial i am not going to say anything
that cuts across these investigations
clearly they're not investigations into
me
but other people are entitled to the
same natural justice as i am and
therefore i'm not going to follow you
down this road
is answering any questions you wish on
the independence campaign which i'm
delighted to participate in uh i need to
ask you this in light of
uh what's happening in ukraine you only
gave up your russia today show in
february you started doing it in 2017.
that was after years of reprimands
towards the channel from ofcon high
profile resignations from employees sick
of being made to give up to give out the
kremlin line yet you took that job why
and now in light of what's happened
subsequently do you regret that do you
think again that has politically
tarnished you
well beth they in terms of reprimands by
ofcom
sky television has many many more than
than
rt managed incidentally that's just a
fact
until at least the the last uh you know
17 in a day which was done in march in
terms of my program i total editorial
independence and and nobody i think
would ever suggest that that program was
anything other than fair
and balanced and gave everybody a chance
to speak and put forward their point of
view
and there was no interference in that
program not even you know for example
when i interviewed peter tatchell about
his experience and
in campaigning for for gay rights during
the world cup and nobody said boo to it
from rt obviously i suspended the
program and then made that permanent uh
on the russian invasion of ukraine
because i thought it was impossible to
conduct the current affairs program in a
a wartime environment but in terms of my
experience with rt as a broadcaster i
had no complaints or difficulties in
terms of russia's foreign policy i'm
afraid my thoughts on that are that
illegal invasions of other countries
never work but then of course my
consistency in opposing illegal
invasions is rather better than other
politicians i mean i've opposed the
legal invasions of countries regardless
of who was doing the invading very few
people can say that you're famously a
betting man
what are the odds of an independent
scotland in your lifetime oh heavy odds
on i mean the royal ascots on today uh
even without her majesty the queen
unfortunately but so royal ascot is on
today i think if
independence in my lifetime was a was a
runner that would be heavy odds on in
the gold cup
okay alex simon thanks so much uh for
talking to me i appreciate your time not
at all thank you any time
alex salmond there well that's all for
today's show thank you to all of our
guests sanith alex salmond
omarosefkovic and thank you for watching